[Music]
i'm sorry i think your things are in my
seat sorry
oh come on you got to be kidding me
excuse me ma'am i need to sit somewhere
else we used to be married worse 19
years of my life we were only married
for five count the recovery
in four days time our daughter is going
to marry a guy she just met ooh bali
millions of miles from home i just
really want to kiss you
it's like i looked up for the first time
and realized everything i ever wanted
was right in front of me
she's throwing a career away just like
her mother did so i'm the only one who
can stop her she doesn't listen to him
champagne oh too please just leave the
bottle
thank you
[Applause]
i won't let her throw her life away we
need to trick her into dumping him as
much as this will paint us both we have
to call a truce to make this work
they're being lockstep
did you make a pact to not murder each
other until you murder me first we are
here for you my love yes we're lost yes
promise no mean comments pretty sure you
don't win anything for eating the whole
pig no arguing
no passive aggression what about
aggressive aggression try to keep the
snoring down i have a nasal
it's a mystery you're still alone
mom dad this is g'day
today
you learned that to make me look bad you
don't need my help there
are you sure they're not sharks come on
don't be a chicken you might be working
with the sharks
i can't believe i got bit by a dolphin
when i do that with you he said pressure
so what's the plan
i say
[Music]
how they look disappointed do you think
we're wrong or not wrong who are we to
say that lily doesn't know what's best
for herself
[Music]
i cannot believe you what are you
talking about she found the rings where
in mom's bag
i knew it what
you clean up pretty good
there you go it's not for the faint of
heart this is not his first rodeo okay
let's go let's go can we get something a
little more age-appropriate for these
two
here we go which one there's only one i
see two
oh yeah
[Music]
oh no no step please stop doing that
oh my god
i'm praying for an asteroid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you